[Music]
so as 2023 comes to a close with
Godzilla Manus 1 and Aquaman the lost
kingdom as the final flicks of the year
to feature big monster we can now look
forward to the new year and a new list
of monsters and Kaiju movies these are
set to be released and to give us food
for thought so let's take a look at 15
of the movies and TV shows about
monsters set to be out in
2024 let's get to it at number one we
still have Monarch the legacy of
monsters well the last episodes so
firstly the monster ver series which has
started on November will have episodes
running all through December till
January of next year while not really
upcoming as a series the final episodes
however will be seen next year and will
feature Godzilla as well as other
gigantic monsters and Titans on
screen number two dist
this is going to be a Sci-Fi comedy
movie and in it a minor extracting
resources from an asteroid belt will
find himself stranded on an alien planet
and as he navigates the landscape he
will face dwindling resources and
pursued by alien monsters produced by
Universal Pictures this movie's January
release is still in question however but
it will be released in
2024 number three Ultram man blazar of
the movie Tokyo Kaiju Showdown yeah a
Japanese movie This is the 35th entry to
the Ultram Man series The Fifth
installment in the Raya era and one of
two Ultram Man movies that will be seen
in 2024 in the movie a character named
gento is revealed to have become the
host of Ultram man blazar leading a task
force against monster Kaiju while
figuring out other things as well number
four Dune part two following the first
dune Movie remake of 2021 the sequel
will pick up from the end of the last
movie as Paul atres seeks revenge
against the conspirators who who
destroyed his family and Endeavors to
prevent a terrible future that only he
can predict and yeah there will be giant
monsters in the form of the Shai hullet
the sand worms number five Ghostbusters
the Frozen Empire the Spangler family
returns to the iconic New York City
Firehouse the original place of the
Ghostbusters to assist the original
Ghostbusters as they create a new
research lab for ghost busting their
discovery of an ancient artifact
unleashes the death chill which is a
mysterious and evil fors here the old
and new Ghostbusters will have to fend
off evil spirits of all shapes and sizes
number six gxk the new Empire Godzilla
and Kong will make their second
monsterverse tee up against new and
deadly Titans that will emerge from the
hollow Earth the monsterverse flagship
movie will feature an array of different
Titans and super species as well as
giant monster fight sequences that will
leave you at the edge of your seat with
an open mouth probably drooling number 7
The House of the Dragon with eight
episodes season 2 of House of the Dragon
will feature the targaryens and their
dragons the on seen in the first season
and newer ones that will make their
debut in this sequel this time the cold
politics of the earlier timeline will
cross over into brutal Warfare pitting
targaryan against Targaryen and Dragons
against dragons for the win number eight
a quiet place day one intended as a
prequel to The Two earlier installments
officially turning the quiet place
movies into a Trilogy this movie will
showcase what happened to the world
right after the meteorite impact
carrying the death angel aliens and how
it will impact the world and set the
stage for the events of the first movie
number nine alien Romulus this will be a
standalone alien movie and the alien in
question is the xenom of yeah finally
many years after alien Covenant we will
see the dreaded zenov in action again
this will be the ninth installment of
the alien franchise and will not be a
sequel to Prometheus or Covenant and as
stated earlier it will be a standalone
movie but then we all know that
Standalone movies are always the
best number 10 Transformers 1
Transformers 1 is an animated action
adventure movie serving as a prequel to
the franchise the film will delve into
the early years of Optimus Prime and
Megatron exploring The Narrative of
their initial meeting and providing a
closer examination of the war unfolding
on their home planet cyber Ron number 11
Venom 3 intended to be the sixth film in
the Sony's Spider-Man universe and the
sequel to Venom and Venom Let There Be
Carnage this flick will feature again
Tom Hardy as the host of the symbiot
called Venom against new threats and
maybe also an Andrew gari Spider-Man
there's also a chance to see antivenom
or toxin two other symbiotes but then
Carnage has been put to rest so maybe we
won't see him anymore number 12 damsel
now this will be a dark fantasy movie
revolving around a dam cell who was
betrayed by her family and sent off as a
sacrifice to repay an ancient dead this
will feature a monstrous dragon in a
cave and a girl who must escape that
gruesome fate with nothing but her wits
and blood armor LOL number 13 Ultraman
Rising Ultraman Rising is an upcoming 3D
computer Graphics animated movie the
second Ultram Man movie of the same year
it will feature a Ken sat
who is the host of Ultraman and after
defeating a deadly Kaiju must adopt the
baby of that monster and raise it as his
own of course there will be other giant
monsters ready to rig Havoc as well
number 14 Jurassic world Chaos Theory
Jurassic world chaos theory is an
upcoming animated series that will be
seen in Netflix and will be a direct
sequel to Jurassic world Camp Cretaceous
the series will be created by Dreamworks
Animation and will be exclusively aired
on Netflix so the dinosaurs of Jurassic
world will be seen again the T-Rex the
Raptors and maybe even new clone
specimens I might presume number 15
stranger things season 5 so the final
installment of the Retro horror series
will be airing probably later in the
final months of the year or at most in
early 2025 if there is no cancellation
in it the town of Hawkins has been torn
by the interdimensional Rifts and
monsters from the upside down will be
tearing people to shreds the demo
gorgens the demo bats the spider
creature and the mind flare will all be
making their appearances again so those
are 15 movies and series featuring big
monster that will be seen next year in
2024 so if you like this video then
watch this other one as well and if
you're more interested in other movie
monsters and creatures then check out
our Channel like subscribe and we'll see
you in the next video take care fam